beautiful that's great
just taking a little walk just walking
hi Mark Wahlberg how you doing but I
heard you just peed in my bathroom it I
used your toothbrush thank you for just
in case let's go sell it on eBay thank
you thank you
I loved your film and I thought you were
great in the departed thank you thank
you Mark thank you
Oh Martin Scorsese how are you doing the
director of The Departed I love that
movie that was fantastic
oh so good good to see you Thank You Man
great you enjoying yourself oh yeah
that's great it does is it is warm in
here though isn't it it's getting a
little hot what is this oh it's a spring
play I wrote that is so weird to screen
play on it it's a screen play right
there yes that is so weird resting it's
a cross between Goodfellas and Big
Momma's House it's called yeah I'm
interested
good Mama's and it's it's a you don't
have time right now I'm sure but I'll
see you at the Governor's Ball really
looks really good thanks I appreciate
just take a look just take a look turn
the shot
great thank you thank you
Hey